évidemment la situation qu'on voit dans
les nouvelles ces jours ci est
inquiétante et nous nous joignons à nos
alliés en exprimant des inquiétudes à ce
niveau là mais évidemment il ya encore
beaucoup de questions qui ont besoin
d'être d'abord des réponses alors on va
pas faire plus de commentaires sur cette
situation et nous était interrogé sur la
disparition l'assassinât probable de ce
journaliste saoudien résidents
américains ces images sont les dernières
de cash l'imaginer il marchait vers la
mort il ignorait certainement mais il
avait peut-être des peurs des caméras de
surveillance l'ont filmé pour la
dernière fois ce 2 octobre alors qu'il
pénétrait et pas n'importe où dans le
consulat d'arabie saoudite à istanbul
son pays en fait il n'existe aucune
preuve de sa sortie du bâtiment à part
peut-être dans un fourgon noir alors
qu'il aurait déjà été assassiné selon le
washington post qui a sorti l'histoire
la turquie détiendrait les preuves que
cache qui a été torturé assassiné dément
briques et ce par une équipe de
renseignement saoudienne que l'on peut
voir sur ces images de l' aéroport on en
parle avec mes chirurgie au quartier
ancien agent du service canadien du
renseignement de sécurité
on se croirait dans un james bond michel
sa patte dans sa wii et c'est la triste
réalité qui prévaut de plus en plus faut
pas se faire de peur ou sous faut pas se
conter de faussetés ça existe depuis
très longtemps depuis palmans la nuit
d'état où les chefs d'état vont utiliser
leurs services de renseignement ou leurs
militaires pour faire des assassinats
comme ça et faire des choses en cachette
habituellement toute fois c'est fait de
manière beaucoup plus discrète
ce qui me choque huile en tout cas
beaucoup plus subtil effectivement on
n'essaie pas de le démontrer les états
qui ont peut-être des preuves ou qui
savent ce qui s'est passé rarement vont
aller scandé sur la place publique
qu'ils ont les preuves et qu'ils ont un
des ondes de l'écouté électronique ou
des shows de gens là dans un consulat ou
dans une ambassade qui théoriquement et
protégées par les conventions
internationales
est-ce que vous s'est répandue que cet
espionnage des consulats ou ambassades
on a récemment on avait des craintes
pour cuba on pense que les rues cif
ça mais en même temps là on est dans un
pays de l'otan
on est en turquie l'arabie saoudite est
une alliée des etats-unis et il va
chercher les documents
il avait peut-être raison d'avoir peur
il avait laissé son cellulaire à
l'extérieur dans sa fiancée c'est grave
comme etc les turcs qui révèle avoir des
preuves vidéo en tout cas nous que nous
n'avons pas vu personne
ils ont donné un compte rendu tout à
fait tout à fait et on le sait il n'ya
pas d'amour perdues entre l'arabie
saoudite et la turquie à l'heure
actuelle non pour répondre à votre
première question al marri oui
effectivement c'est très très très
répondre par des pendus ça s'est
toujours fait depuis des décennies
l'espionnage entre les états et
particulièrement les états qui ont une
propension à la sécurité ou à
l'offensive
il ya des pays qui ont des services de
renseignement offensif mais certainement
les pays qui veulent se défendre comme
lens moment c'est le consulat saoudien
qui se trouvent en territoire turc
via la turquie va justifier peut-être de
vouloir faire de l'espionnage pur du
contre espionnage pour pouvoir se
protéger
c'est malheureusement une pratique qui
est commune très commune et qui se fait
à la grandeur de la planète
c'est comme d'ailleurs les diplomates
canadiens reçoivent une formation
spéciale avant de partir en assignation
ou on les informe et on leur enseigne
faire attention parce qu'on prend pour
acquis que leurs voitures leurs
résidences privées et l'ambassade ou le
consulat où ils se trouveront doit avoir
des espions ou de un système d'écouté
électronique dans les soirs on sait que
la cia et le mossad lagence secrète
israélienne
la cia et ont commis des meurtres un peu
partout ça servait leurs intérêts
nationaux
mais dans ce cas-ci que l'impact meurtre
appréhender ce meurtre probable peut
avoir d'après vous sur le monde la
diplomatie des renseignements passe mal
on voit les visuels on voit l'équipe
saoudienne arrive l aéroport on la voit
repartir on voit fourgon dans lequel il
l'aurait été sinon voulait l'enlever
part et si l'on voulait pas le tuer nous
est quelque chose de pas et allait mal
tourné lorsque sylla et bel bel et bien
été torturé là vous poser une question
très intéressant d'un mari parce que
effectivement faut voir qu'est-ce que ça
va avoir sur l'ensemble des relations
diplomatiques parce que si on regarde
depuis quelques années on a vu la russie
qui a fait deux temps de une qui a
réussi assassiné un dissident qui est
fun tentatives sur deux autres personnes
on a vu la chine récemment qui a arrêté
le directeur de l'interpol alors qu'il
rentrait à la maison on a vu des pays
comme les etats-unis israël et d'autres
faire aussi des à ces assassinats
sélectifs de cette manière là si les
états commencent à se permettre
ouvertement avec la montée en plus des
gouvernements populistes comme on a vu
entre autres aux philippines où le
gouvernement se cache même pas d'avoir
procédé à l'exécution de dizaines de
milliers de personnes
alors on voit ici peut-être une tendance
qui est en train de se faire et ça c'est
très dangereux justement pour les
relations internationales très dangereux
pour les diplomates qui rompt n'importe
où par ce que il se peut fort bien
maintenant parce qu'on voit de plus en
plus aussi de gouvernement de la droite
et de l'extrême droite prendre les rênes
de leur poule du pouvoir décider de
pouvoir assassiné un voisin qui a été
élu démocratiquement dans un pays
démocratique mais qui est un peu
embarrassant pour eux en même temps
c'est l'arabie saoudite qui a reçu un
résident américain
journaliste au marché toute la famille
du washington post évidemment étant est
en deuil
on laisse entendre que les services de
renseignements américains auraient pu
est informé de de l'idée de l'arabie
saoudite d'enlever au moins car à chier
de le ramener
by saoudite qu'est ce que vous pensez
des hypothèses là mais on veut enquêter
aller au fond des choses et c est ce qu
on peut penser que les services de
renseignement est été informé de ce plan
funeste réagit pas beaucoup il va
peut-être appelé le roi ce soir dit il
mais oui c'est très difficile pour
d'imaginer où peut il croire à ce moment
si j'allais avoir des preuves ou plus
intéressante
vous savez lorsque des évènements très
très extraordinaire de cette nature ont
lieu souvent les les rumeurs de la
conspiration fourmillent à gauche et à
droite c'est pas impossible c'est pas
non plus prouvé dans cette perspective
là je ne vois pas que les états unis
auraient quoi que ce soit à gagner même
de se rapprocher de l'état saoudien
c'est le peux je crois l'état saoudien
capable de le faire abondamment tout
seul sans avoir besoin de qui que ce
soit ou de quoi que ce soit c'est
certain que ça mais ici le tout les
gouvernements occidentaux on l'a vu par
l'attitude de monsieur trudeau mais
c'est monsieur trompe pas ou si elle est
un peu dans l'embarras avec quelque
chose de gens là parce que c'était
abondamment rapprocher de l'arabie
saoudite dont les contrats sont
importants de vente d'armes vers
l'arabie saoudite
alors jamais sa magnifique demain tout
le monde dans l'embarras cette situation
ce qui n'est pas peut-être déplaisant
pour la turquie que de mettre l'occident
dans l'embarras contenu que la turquie a
été mis à l'index
avec les récentes bouleversements
politiques qu'on a vu ces dernières
années la prise de possession du pouvoir
du gouvernement et c'est alors dans
cette perspective là on voit qu'il ya
des jeux maintenant mais moi ce qui me
préoccupe c'est que ces jeux là ne sont
de plus en plus ouvertement annoncé où
il se déroule devant nous et on ne
semble plus avoir les lignes de
deux restrictions et de retenue que l'on
avait antérieurement
et ça ça peut déborder ça peut déborder
vers les démocraties c'est un prix d'un
dernier un dernier point intéressant
lorsqu'on dit que le mystère est complet
l'énigme est complexe
sauf que depuis par viale agence reuter
déjà le 10 octobre et encore plus
aujourd'hui vont aussi que des audio
vidéo personne ne les a vus ni entendus
c'est un compte rendu des turcs
on présume qu'ils sont vrais leurs
comptes rendus mais que la fameuse
montre à paul ii de la plus belle
victime aurait révélé des renseignements
ne serait ce que par la géolocalisation
pour cherche à savoir par le icloud
parce que c'est la fiancée qui avait le
cellulaire dumont évocation james bond
tout à l'heure donc il y aurait à
travers ces technologies
une preuve de ce qui se passe est
potentiellement on pourrait avoir
certaines informations effectivement
c'est certain qu'en révélant ouvertement
les prochains qui voudront tenter de
faire quelque chose vont s'assurer de
s'occuper de la montre et s'il y en a
une on vient de donner une autre recette
ici pour mieux faire mais dans cette
perspective là effectivement la
technologie va de plus en plus être
utilisés inutilisables et comme on a la
mine miniaturisation de plus en plus
mais là on va pouvoir dissimuler des
choses et peut-être retrouver des choses
qu'on aurait qu'on croyait dissimuler
comme il faudrait fsa qui parlait de
james bond merci michel toujours plaisir
à tenir la prochaine on sourit c'est
vraiment tragique cette foire le merci
beaucoup michel d'après claire